اشعل الربيع العربي صراعات فكريه وثقافيه
وسياسيه لا يزال بعضها مستعرا حتى اليوم
كان للفقه نصيبه من تلك الصراعات فما هو
مفهوم المعارضه في الاسلام وكيف يمكن
قراءه الخلاف الفقهي بشانها هل هناك تعريف
واضح للمعارضه السياسيه في الفقه الاسلامي
وعرض السياسيه كمصطلح هي مصطلح معاصر
وليس بالضروره ان نجد تعريفا قديما لهذا
المصطلح في حدود ما عرف عليه في هذا
الزمان معارضه سياسيه في الاصطلاح اليوم
فاقول هي حق الافراد في الاعتراض على
الدوله او الحاكم بما يصحح المسار او يعيد
الامور الى نصابها الصحيح من وجهه نظر
المعارضه او المعترضين الفكر الاسلامي هل
هناك معارضه اخرى غير معارضه السياسيه
معارضه سياسيه قلت لك اخي هو مصطلح معاصر
لكن اذا رجعنا الى فكره المعارضه او
التعارض سنجد ان هناك فعلا فضاء اوسع
واطار ارحب بالاكثر من ذلك انا اقول ان
الاسلام يعطي حمايه لهذا الحق ويعطيه بعدا
دينيا تجد عندنا التعارض الفقهي او اعتراض
الراي الفقي تجد عندنا التعارض في الراي
الشوري اقصد في اطار الشورى وفي قضايا
الشان العام تجد عندنا اكثر من ذلك واوسع
من ذلك حق المسائله حق المساءله للحاكة
هذا حق لكل مواطن مسلم بمعنى انه يعترض
على تصرف من تصرفات الحاكم ما اختلف
الصحابه رضي الله عنهم مع وجود النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم وياتي الوحي بعد ذلك يسدد
او يصوت او يوجه باتجاه الماء هذا الخلاف
الفقيه استمر بين الصحابه والتابعين وتجلى
بعد ذلك في المدارس والمذاهب الفقهيه والى
من هذا ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
كان يدرب هذه الامه بدا من اصحابه رضي
الله عنهم على قضيه الشورى ما هي الشورى
شورى هي اخذ راي الاخرين او استشاره
الاخرين في قضيه من قضايا نسميها الان
قضايا من العام ما مدام مشروعيه المعارضه
السياسيه في الاسلام استطيع ان اقول انه
هذا الحق محترم في الاسلام بل اكثر من ذلك
قد يرقى الى ان يكون واجبا انا استطيع ان
اقول ان الاسلام وضع الاطار الارحام من
خلال عنوان او شعار النصيحه وعندنا بابان
رئيسيان في هذا يؤكدان هذا الحق كتاب
الجهاد اول مراتب التهاب هو جهاد الكلمه
ونجد الحقيقه من النصوص ما يؤكد هذا
الواجب باب الامر بالمعروف والنهي عنه تجد
من النصوص الحقيقه الشيء الكثير الذي
يؤكدها مثل
لما يقول النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم افضل
الجهاد كلمه حق في روايه كلمه عدل عند
سلطان جائر
تباين حدث نتيجه الاختلاف في مفهوم
المعارضه هل هو خروجنا الحاكم ام هو
نصح له وتبين
الاختلاف حدث بسبب انه تعارض الظاهره بين
النصوص الامره بالطاعه وبين النصوص الامره
بتغيير المنكر عندما ناتي للحديث عن
الخروج على الحاكم لا هناك تفصيلات اخرى
هناك مراتب وانواع من الحكام وكل حاكم له
احكامه وما نصل الى الخروج الا ضمن يعني
شروط مشدده والاصل عندنا هي الطاعه للحاكم
المسلم
هذا الاعتراض انما يكون ايضا بادب الاسلام
ليس القصد هنا لا تجريح ولا التشويش ولا
التشويه ولا الانتقاص انما هو القصد منه
بيان الحق والوصول الى الحق ورد الامام هل
هناك فارق بين المعارضه وبين النصيحه يعني
هي الخطوه الاولى وغالبا ما يراد منها ان
تكون سره هي نصيحه كخطوه اولى او مرتبه
اولى من مراتب السعي للوصول الى احقاق
الحق واقامه العدل وازاله المنكر اذا حصل
للاسف
يخلط بعض الناس بين انواع من الائمه واقسم
بالله اما هنا الحكام الاصل في الحاكم ان
يكون مسلما عادلا يقيم شرع الله ويقيم
الشعار هذا باتفاق الامه اجماع الامه هذا
الحاكم العادل تجب طاعته ولا يجوز الخروج
عليه لكن لا يوجد دائما هذا الحاكم مسلم
العادل ويحصل خروج والخروج يتفاوت اقصد
خروج عن شرع الله لذلك وجدنا العلماء
يتكلمون عن الحاكم الفاسد قال وفسقه فيما
بينه وبين ربه يتكلمون عن الحاكم الظالم
الذي تعدى ظلمه الى العامه او على الاقل
الى بعض الناس
ثم يتكلمون عن الحاكم الكافر طبعا لا
يتصور ان يكون حاكم كافر في امه مسلمه في
بلاد مسلمه لكن ربما يكون المقصود انه كان
مسلما وترى عليه الكفر تكييف ما حصل في
ثورات الربيع العربي التي طر الناس فيها
في بعض البلاد الى حمل السلاح هو دفاع
مشروع عن نفسه وليس خروجا على حاكم شرعي
من البدايه دائره الاحتجاجات وحتى
المظاهرات يجب ان لا نختلف على انها
مشروعه ومقبوله من منظور شرعي وبالتالي
الذي حصل بعد ذلك اخي الكريم ان الانظمه
المستبده المفتقده اصلا للشرعيه لانه لم
تاتي بطريقه شرعيه انما جاءت بالانقلابات
جاءت على دار الدبابات هذه الانظمه التي
تفتقد الشرعيه هي التي حملت سلاح ووجهته
الى صدور المتظاهرين والمحتاجين
والمعترضين اضطر الناس اضطرارا لحمل
السلاح للدفاع عن انفسهم عن اعراضهم عن عن
اهليهم تجربه الاسلاميه الاولى والحديثه
كان هناك اخضاع للسياسي لصالح الديني كان
المهيمن هو الديني بمعنى اخر بحسب كلمات
والحلاق كانت الشريحه للنطاق المركزي
للامه وليست الدوله الان مع الحاجات
المعارضه حاليا نتكلم عن الدوله والسياسه
هي الاصل وليس الفرع وبالتالي فرق مهم جدا
الامر الثاني متعلق بانه في العصر الاول
للاسلام لم تكن المعارضه تنازع الدوله
الشرعيه كانت هناك شرعيه معروفه بالدوله
الاسلاميه لكن في المرحله الحاليه وعلى
الاقل خلال اخر 100 سنه بنتكلم على انه
الاصل في المساله والسياسه هو الصراع
السياسي هو السلطه او الحكم عندما ننظر
مثلا على سبيل المثال ان من كتبوا في
السياسه في الفتره الاولى للاسلام لم
يكونوا سياسيين كانوا قضاه فقهاء علماء
حاليا بنتكلم عن طبقه جديده وفئه جديده
معظمهم من الافنديه كما كانوا يسموا القرن
العشرين في جماعه الاخوان المسلمين ما
يتعلق بمفهوم السياسه السياسه كانت في
الماضي اقرب لمساله فرعيه وليست مساله
اصليه نحن في الحركات الاسلاميه حاليا
حركات تتعامل مع اعتبارها اصل وليست فرع
وكيف تتعامل تلك الحركات مع فقه المعارضه
في التراث الاسلامي على التيار العام في
حركات الاسلاميه
واقصد بذلك الحركات المتفرعه عن جامعه
الاخوان المسلمين يتعامل مع الامر الواقع
سياسيا ليس فقهيا المكون الفقهي او الديني
بشكل او باخر مكون قد يكون هو الاضعف ضمن
حلقات التكوين داخل داخل الحركات المملات
الاخوان المسلمين محركات الاسلاميه في
النهايه حركات حداثيه وحديثه نشات الدوله
الحديثه هي بنت الدوله الحديثه بشكل او
باخر وبالتالي هي بتستلهم كل ما يتعلق
بالاحتجاج سواء كان احتجاجا من خلال العمل
السياسي من عمل الحزبي لعمل الجماهير
العمل التعبوي تلعب سياسه من خلال القواعد
اللعبه المعروفه للجميع وبالتالي هي تستند
بالاساس الى الواقع السياسي ليس الواقع
الفقهي او الى البعد الفقهي داخل الكريم
ان نفصل ونفصل بين البعد الفقهي وال
الواقعي فهم الواقع والتعامل مع الواقع هو
جزء من ديننا هو جزء من احكام السياسه
الشرعيه تجربه الحركه الاسلاميه المعاصره
هي تجربه راشده متزنه منضبطه باحكام
وقواعد السياسه الشرعيه انا اعتقد لابد ان
نفرق بين تجارب الحركات الاسلاميه في
السلطه كما تعلق الموقف من المعارضه لدينا
على الاقل خلال اخر عشر سنوات ثلاث تجارب
مرت بهم الحركه الاسلاميه في ثلاث دول
الحاله المصريه والحاله التونسيه والحاله
المغربيه حالتين من هذه الحالات الثلاثه
تم اجهاضهم من خلال انقلابات الحاله
المصريه عام واحد فقط للسلطه بتامر الصعب
جدا ان نحكم على موقفها موقف الخال المسلم
المعربه التجربه التونسيه عشر سنوات تم
عليها عام 2021 مع انقلاب قيس سعيد بنتكلم
ايضا عن مساحه كبيره جدا للمعارضه في
الحاله التونسيه درجه انه كان هناك محاوله
للتعزيز حركه النهضه وتعزيز كل من كانوا
في البرلمان خلال اخر خمس سنوات المغربيه
انا اعتقد كان هناك غلبه لمنطق الدوله على
سلوكه حز دائما نتعامل مع النصوص الوارده
في الباب الواحد بنظره اجماليه لا يجوز ان
ناخذ بعض النصوص ونهمل بعضها بحجه التمسك
بهذا النصر هل اتاحت الانظمه السياسيه
المعاصره شكلا للاعتراض خارج هذه الثنائيه
ثنائيه السيف والصبر بعتقد خيار تجربه اخر
خمسين سنه هناك تجارب مختلف في العالم
الاسلامي العالم العربي تحديدا كما يتعلق
بالتعاقب مع المعارضات للاسف الشديد معظم
الحالات كان هناك قمع شديد جدا لكل من
يعارض السلطه هناك تجارب مختلفه لكن بشكل
عام المهيمن عليه هو القمع والاستبداد ضد
هذه الحركات